my brother took some money from you
right with her finger paying you back he
promised to pay you back and everything
like this then
he's crazy
as I am as well okay right then you
change his number yeah then after the
person who Tracked Down the um the
person who took the money he contacts
him
the guy who took the money says he
doesn't know who you are then he really
recognized you I said don't bother or if
you keep on asking for the money I'll
call the feds what do you make of a
brother like this
he's a liar
yeah
he might be listening now yeah I don't
know him
no no a general message
[Applause]
[Music]
if it's next time here and you're here
then we sit together that's what we do
because like I said according to
yourself
too many people last week
according to this statement if if
someone
yeah the guy who took your money or
anyone that takes his brother's money
sell
is Haram
our new place so we are still looking
for the place of course if you haven't
seen it go back to our channel to see
our current place to handle in the back
of the alleyway in the market the place
is not a good place so we are raising
money to find a new place please donate
generously and the the the details is in
the description box
[Applause]
I mean
if we take money from people we should
give it back to them you know we should
not take in money from the people with
Haram you know we as a Muslims remember
a man as a trust it's a trust a manner
if you ask about it you know
we don't want to die with the debts you
know subhanallah
because on that day the day of
Resurrection we don't even have enough
good distance save us let alone give my
goodness someone else that's why someone
came to him he said yeah Imam I've heard
you back bite me
he said if I want to backbit anyone I
will back about my mother and father
because by backbizing them I will give
them a good deeds so if I want to give
my goodness to anyone I will give it to
my parents first before I give it to you
you know subhanallah so so Allah
you know that's why I said according to
his speech no doubt but you know and
when it comes to judging between people
you need to people
yeah yeah
you have to sit both side down that's
the husband is a general advice
foreign
someone gave you any money amount of
money and you try to give it back to her
or to him but you cannot so what you do
you try your best if you cannot then the
score is mentioned you give as a charity
on her behalf or his behalf and now if
you give it as a charity then you meet
him or meet her later on and she said
you know my sister I'm not happy I want
my money back then you give the money
back and what you have given as a
charity will be in your good deeds
because and also I want to mention
something you know just I don't want to
mention the brother's name a brother
sent me a video of his brother
speaking about a Christian
and the argument that is Baba use Angus
Christian can be used against the
Muslims too
you understand
so as we know a Muslim it is regardless
what sins he would do they will not take
him to Hell Fire except if he fall into
nullifies Islam
rape in a woman is a major sin in Islam
you receive a capital punishment because
not just adultery you are forcing
yourself
according to 100 subscribers
if I'm wrong
damn because you know just had a
intercourse outside marriage or adultery
you force the woman yes however in Islam
a woman getting raped is not
justification for her to reject Allah
because oh a man getting raped or
whatever you know that's just it's not
justification for these people this
emotional arguments you because knowing
Allah and worshiping Allah every part of
our body testified to that that's why it
accepts Allah as our Lord and worship
him alone Islamic is so clear when the
atheists try to look for any excuses to
reject Allah there's not any doubt he
boils down to two I have mentioned that
many times two factors ah that is a
psychological factor for example it's
emotional factor I got raped you know
that's Haram is forbidden Islam rather
than Islam will not put him in prison
and we'll take care of them we'll treat
them better than the victim you know
Islam They will receive severe
punishment even and Allah's Faith
however is under Allah's will because
there is no sin worse than rejects Allah
so you have to be careful we're not here
to please another Muslim are saying you
know if the brother who says subhanallah
couldn't believe it I mean if the
Christian woman he was speaking to if
she knew she would flip it on him it's
about you believe if a Muslim regards
what sins he would do if he does up
until you eat he'll go to Jannah yes
maybe he'll be passed with the father
but he will not be in a fire forever you
go to Jannah eventually you go to Jannah
because the greatest sin
because many people don't know the
meaning of shirk
all Injustice that you see is coming
from there you understand
so that's the problem but if someone now
like
when there was a man who killed many
companions
sahaba
and maybe ask yourself
his companions caused him
his company's caught him yeah and they
put him in the Masjid was looking for
him for a long time he was known as
so he came and the person said do you
know who who you have captured who he
said
um
he said yes to take care of him he
became
muslimation on deaf judgment when there
will be two that the murderer and there
was been murdered together
how the murderer will become Muslim
afterwards and then I forgive all the
sins and on death judgment Allah is just
Allah will give the victim who are
Justified
satisfy him or satisfy her understand so
the calamities even as some squares
mentioned the calamities happened to the
Quran
by the way subscribe
that Allah will lighten their punishment
under their Resurrection but they're
gonna have forever so don't look for any
justification to reach Allah because the
greatest sin against Allah will return
away from him everything that exists who
went towards Allah
that's why the atheist if you notice
they will look for anything others
emotional arguments which covers
psychological factor or social arguments
which goes back to I'm someone that my
people look up to me how can I live how
can I become a Muslim and I believe this
is the case of Bob
Paperboy I don't know what's wrong with
his name is paper boy it's a cartoon man
that's why they call themselves paper
boy and other they know Islam is the
truth
they know that they know but you today
they are well respected amongst the
communities they don't want to become a
Muslim that's why Islam is so clear when
you expand to people naturally you
gravitate towards Islam so nothing stop
you there's many Muslims being Muslims
women being restraints
Muslim sisters in Syria will lie the
Muslims in Syria and Palestine you learn
how to be strong in Iman from them
they've been raped in a prison they've
been murdered their father hasn't been
murdered but did they change their
religion they said the Muslim and when
you hear from them alhamdulillah
you know so this justification don't be
because you've been raped which is evil
act no doubt about that you know if you
go psychologically you know if because
Islam pays attention if you become
Disturbed mentally then Islam the
prophet Muhammad said you will not be
accountable for whatever you're gonna
say or you're gonna do because the plan
is being ripped up because sanity is not
there something mentally disturbs you
you understand and I'll show you just
Islam but if you are there you should
not utilize whatever happened to this
Allah Quran many things will happen to
us in this universe which will disturb
us which is however Allah mentioned this
life is full of tests and Allah
mentioned that
looks awesome said they will bring a
person all his life just hardship all
his life they put me to gender and they
ask him also on so have you ever
tasted in your hardship he said never in
my life
never understand and they'll be a person
all his life
enjoy this life is a careful doing
everything he never wants for hardship
they put me together and they will say
to him also and so have you ever enjoyed
your life he said me never the
punishment of the fire may Allah protect
us from The Passion of the fire and may
Allah
and to us and our parents and our loved
ones into Jannah without any Reckoning
and without any punishment
so we have to be careful we should not
be using argument against Christians for
the sake to make them look bad for unto
their liberal and so on but this
argument can be used against you too
that's what the Christians do here speak
his Kona we're not here to please people
and there's nothing worse than a shirk
there is nothing worse than a cover
because why everything that exists even
your fitra
arrogant
that's why people are there
what's an evil destination for the evil
ones
so again no answer to misquote me rape
is an evil act in Islam capital
punishment we don't put them in prison
we take care of them
the rapists you understand we don't we
give them food they go to gym they play
football in prison they watch TV 24 7
they have PlayStation now you'll be
punished severely and that's why I've
noticed many people who hate Sharia
because they are they are criminals
Islam is good for mankind
so why you hate it because you are
Criminal
yeah because the criminal you know he
hates what he had kind of severe
punishment or you've been all you are
either a criminal yourself or ignorance
you don't know about Islam so we clarify
to you you know so Islam came as we have
mentioned to preserve what
five things life wealth and so on and
finish
so it's just a reminder we have to be
careful I mean obviously make mistakes
all of us sometimes we say something
maybe in a time of anger or something
may Allah forgive us all if I made any
mistake you can correct me whatever I
said you can challenge me alhamdulillah
correct me I'm the end of the damn human
being you know I make mistakes